all right ted back shortly tonight is
the night golden knights fans will be
back
at the fortress t-mobile arena of course
won't be packed
like normal it will be again but not
tonight but it is a step in the right
direction
sports director chris matthews joining
us there chris we have been waiting for
this night
yeah we really have brian you mentioned
a small step a baby step in the right
direction
it's been nearly a year since fans were
allowed back inside
to watch the vegas golden knights but
they will be there tonight in fact the
2600
that will be in there tonight must feel
like charlie and charlie and the
chocolate factor in that willy wonka
movie because they have the golden
ticket
they're going to be inside witnessing a
real good game between the top two teams
in the west division
when the vegas gold knights take on the
minnesota wild let's head
south on toshiba plaza here and get the
latest from those excited fans bringing
kevin
martin kevin i know they're excited to
get inside
yeah chris you got that right you know
it's exactly two days short of a year
march third of last year was the last
time that we saw golden faint golden
knights fans inside t-mobile arena while
the wait ends tonight and
earlier i caught up with two lucky fans
that will be inside tonight take a
listen
i am very excited it's been almost a
year now we get
vegas is open we're back down here and
it's great to get out
with my wife diane i can't wait in diane
only 2600 fans but we all know the
medieval maniacs you guys are
loud you're proud what are you expecting
the atmosphere to be like in there
tonight
super everybody's super excited
it's we're gonna try to be as loud as it
is during a normal game so we're
totally we're ready we're high i love it
and what have you guys missed the most
about being inside there
uh well i miss the the whole group
activity with the uh the whole pregame
stuff and cheerleaders yeah it's the
wildest show of any any hockey arena
anywhere it's just the best
yeah two of the top teams in the west
going at it tonight obviously the golden
knights the wild do you have any
predictions
we're gonna win go knights go
now to keep kovid safe congregating is
not permitted at all on toshiba plaza
and each fan that does have a ticket to
get inside has a designated time to
enter the arena so there will be no
crowds
of any kind outside of the arena tonight
the doors open at 5 45
and you can bet fans are waiting and
excited to get inside now let's head
back over to chris
who has a preview of this huge west
division matchup hey chris
hey kevin you're right it's going to be
a big big matchup the guy flying the
flags tells us all right he's been at
every single game it's going to be big
he got minnesota
taking on vegas you know we mentioned
this the top two teams in the west
division
now this team has provided some fits for
the vegas guy golden knights over the
years
remember that first year all these games
were pretty exciting
now minnesota comes into this game as
the hottest team
in the nhl right now having won six
straight games they are absolutely
red-hot
minnesota's outscored its opponents
27-10 over those six
games but for the next six are against
the vegas golden knights now vegas has
mark andre fleury
he's been one of the top goalies in the
league he's been talked about for that
vesna trophy
given to the top goalie in the league at
the end of the season he's only allowed
10 goals
in his last seven games now tonight will
come down to defense
who plays it best vegas leads the league
in many defensive categories they're
number one and having allowed
just 35 goals against and that line of
alex patrangelo and shea theodore
probably the best top unit in the league
so look for some exciting hockey tonight
when you're pre-scouting a team we
usually go back three or four games and
watch
the previous three or four games they've
won six in a row
uh and and their game's real you look at
their lineup they've got a sneaky deep
lineup
uh when you've got bonino as your fourth
line center and
paris a on your third line you know
that's a deep team
they've always had good defense you know
i think their
their game even last year was good they
didn't get
a lot of goaltending uh and they're
getting that this year so
this is a really dangerous team this is
definitely going to be for me one of the
the four teams standing uh come playoff
time
all right to give you an idea how big
this game is tonight moneypunk.com
factors in all sorts of stats and they
have the wild as the third most likely
team to reach the postseason
and the top team in the league to get to
the stanley cup finals
at 8.7 percent vegas is at 5.3 percent
to win that cup hey if you're wondering
what they're going to wear tonight the
vegas gold knights on the ice they're
going to wear those
gray jerseys tonight but coming up on
wednesday against the wild
bill foley's favorite the gold jersey
much more for you tonight
at six and later tonight at 11 on this
exciting night for many of these fans
back inside the fortress to watch the
top two teams in the west
we'll have much more for you reporting
live from toshiba plaza chris
matthews 8 sports now